quite often I've been driving down some
highway and I'll see a road that just
off of that highway and wondered for
does that road go travel is extremely
important not a luxury it's a necessity
I feel getting out into the middle of
nowhere helps you recharge my name is
Britton purser I own a company called
vintage overland we build tear drop camp
trailers we being my two younger
brothers and myself we are located in
Grand Junction Colorado
this is Britain's business
this is idea this is product that he's
come up with he started getting phone
calls a lot I have a long-standing crazy
love for these vintage trailers I just
love them it's not like in the realm of
destiny like I got to go do this sheer
drops were first introduced after World
War two
the reasons they have the materials that
they use the jeep wheels the aluminum
paint of that nature is quite simply
they were using army surplus between the
three of us we've done it all all the
trades carpentry tile work sheetrock
electric plumbing bubble in all of that
cabinetry phase one is the woodworking
face so we put the pattern down on here
and we trace their line and I cut it
rough with the jigsaw very imprecise I'm
just getting most of the material out of
the way and now I'm going to put the
pattern clamp the pattern back on here
and I'm going to route out to a finer
degree with the router against our
pattern make a more precise
[Music]
what I'm doing right now is building
what we call the H frame it's really the
sign of the trailer in the shop it's
mostly calling at me where it doesn't
have time he's making phone calls and
answering phone calls and selling so we
cut out the wood finish everything put
the box together so now we have a wooden
box a lot of people don't understand
handhold but they're absolutely the
quickest to get things done a lot of
times I try to do the maximum amount of
quality with the bare minimum of tools
building each Caravan it takes
approximately two weeks to assemble and
finish the second step is we insulate
the box and then we skin it with
aluminium
[Music]
it's a soft aluminum so we have to be
very careful in the shop we dent the
side of the trailer we got to pull that
piece of skin off and put a new one back
on so it's just it's learning to work
very precisely and carefully Kody's role
and this has been could be an absolute
pain in the butt I like like never happy
it is never good enough
are you flush good okay if it was
written in myself I'd be pretty nice
it'd be pretty nice but with codeine
mixed they're unbelievably over-the-top
[Music]
this just came back from the powder
coater put the completed box on a frame
and we jacked that frame up put the
wheels on it :
starts making the side doors and then we
work on the rear hatch door Aquabat it's
finishing detail I get inside and we put
in some trim
abbis which is just device online
beautiful and beautiful all three speed
[Music]
we put in a flight out table and then
after that we peel all the protective
plastic off the aluminum just be very
careful because these knives will
scratch the surface put on the decal
slightly put in place P off this real
slow and very last step is to put the
hop cap off because their chrome we
wanted to be no scratches and we just
put them on and it goes pop that sense
of relief and now we can get on to the
next one
[Music]
what I envision is you take that Caravan
and not with a new vehicle you take it
with an old vehicle you take it with an
old Jeep you take it with an old Land go
over our caravans are built to be taking
off road
takes you to areas that not everyone can
get you the thing about these trailers
is not what they are but what they
aren't they are not an RV these are
symbols of simplicity they're symbols
sanctuary solitude get inside them and I
don't know if it's the feeling of a womb
but the roundness inside and the warmth
of wood they're a retreat that goes with
you the whole goal is for someone who
purchases the caravan for us not to go
somewhere that that's not the point the
point is to go nowhere cooler in the
middle of nowhere you go out and you
camp you look at a fire and you realize
all that matters is food in your belly
warm protection and it's just good to go
remember that
and then you go back into the nonsense
then it doesn't threaten you quite as
much and freedom versus security yeah
yeah and we choose for you
[Music]
you